[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that you beside me
without everyone just a quick intro
before we get started what you're about
to hear hear
you're here here here here here here
here
what you're about to hear is man I love
this one right I think this was your
favorite event from the first wave of
the tour Oh am i right
oh my god I mean the the way the Boston
crowd made it made me feel when we got
on stage everyone was like just we were
all in the same page it was just really
really I'm going to say awesome but I
overuse that word so much it really was
awesome though yeah I mean this is an
appropriate you saw that wherever we got
out on on the stage and there's what
over a thousand people there for sure
and and like they'd the crowd was just
great the questions were engaging and
thoughtful and it lasted all my joke and
they did even the ones that were your
normal joke yeah well they would
disagree with you they were outstanding
joke yeah well it was a great event it
was you know what it's very rare that I
can say like we do for events in a row
like we did this last wave and all of
them were outstanding but I do feel that
way on more of these and we're releasing
all for us as podcasts and I'm gonna
don't know about you but I've got a
bunch of really good feedback on the
Twitter's ad jsm a lot of people have
been been tweeting me just saying hey I
really love seeing how you people
interact you people I said who what do
you mean you people minimal if you think
all middle would look the same because
we have great hair no like you know what
I really enjoy watching out how you and
Ryan interact with people sort of live
this this tete-a-tete we usually take
callers on the podcast which I love
doing that as well but they're not it's
not direct callers necessarily although
we are building a podcast studio right
now and we're in the
costas doing it we need some funding for
that so we just started a patreon page
if you want to support us help us do the
studio thing and also do a video or film
studio so we can add a video component
to that we can also do new cool video
stuff like many documentaries and
interviews and bring guests on but also
we could take a live color so if you
like how we're interacting with people
but with radically improved audio audio
quality then if you would just support
us on patreon what a do because we're
just impossible I know right Ryan that
is racist no I have you I want to
interact with people on the phone but we
need the audio equipment or the audio
equipment for those of you in Boston
right and it's so bad we started oh come
on do that one dude he came up to us
after the bus event even that he's like
he would he say uh something about how
you know there's a Bostonian saying he
was like and he like laid on the accent
really thick he was like you guys are a
wicked pissah sir did you just come here
from Belfast which I hope to make it
back developable here that would be
really great anyway the Boston event was
outstanding for those of you listening
at home if you want to support us we're
looking for 1% support so if one person
of our listeners can support us that's
just over 5,000 people actually that's
probably half of one put your contribute
a million dollars apiece
no no it's $1 Ryan Oh a dollar or two
bucks what we're trying to get what
we're trying to do is get one or two
dollars per episode so that we can build
the studio so if you want to support us
welcome first off to our first 200 or so
patreon supporters if you want to go
over just to patreon.com/scishow a
livestream where you can interact with
the minimal su gasps with questions
participate it's only for our patreon
supporters if you're doing two bucks or
more per episode but also it's really
cool patreon allows you to cap it allows
you to cap your monthly usage or your
your monthly contribution to any any of
any place that you contribute to so if
you and I were to start like putting out
30 episodes a month all of a sudden
that'd be great as long as they were all
good meaningful creations we're not
going to expect you to contribute to all
30 of those so you can put a cap if you
want to that's great but basically all
we're saying is if you want to
contribute to the cause be part of the
1% help us build the studio none of that
money goes to me and Ryan it all goes to
either pay a salary for Sean and you can
help support his family that way
Podcast sean is our producer or just as
important it helps us fund the equipment
that we need 2,000 supporters it gets us
the audio studio that we need 5,000 gets
us the video component allows us to hire
a full-time filmmaker as well so we can
create a lot more meaningful videos for
you you can find the details of that on
our patreon page or just go to the
minimalists comm and click on the donate
button up there you can find all the
ways to support the the podcast
Ryan Drive oh yeah we're we're hitting
the road again already you were gone for
a while you and I just recorded a
podcast episode about your trip to Tokyo
hopefully that will we'll be out really
soon that was supposed to be the
original intro to the Ballston podcast
we end up talking for like an hour
instead because you and I hadn't caught
up yet like you literally how did you
sleep at all
oh dude like I don't have to be so off
right now go alright did I got okay good
well I tried not to sleep on the plane
and on the way back so like an 18-hour
trip back which actually the lay overs
were like six hours it really wasn't
that bad like time in the air um I've
got we got back I went to more Mariah I
went to sleep too this is crazy
Mariah I went this legal 1:30 a.m. I
guess that would make it Sunday morning
we have X Saturday night like 11 p.m.
and they went to sleep like 1:30 a.m.
right early Sunday morning technically
and I didn't set an alarm and I'm like
oh you know like a getting 8 9 hour so
we woke up at 3 p.m. yesterday mountain
time so you actually with the bed last
night still yeah and then yeah so and
then I went to yeah and then I went to
bed like 10:00 p.m. and woke up it's
10:30 p.m. when when got up at like 6
o'clock wow I'm good in yeah that's
great man no I'm not like that is not
sleeping it doesn't take away the jet
lag all together but like I feel totally
fine now dude but like not sleeping on
the plane on those long plane rides like
that too we did that on the way over to
Tokyo it helped out a ton again took me
a day or two to like get into the rhythm
so just but it wasn't like that for
every hour time difference it takes a
day I mean I was not you know by the
third or fourth day I was fine right so
so we did a whole episode on our sort of
media follow up we did a media episode
and so absolutely just recorded that
we're not going to air just yet but
we'll try to put out maybe later this
week or next week or sometime we wanted
to get this Boston to the natthew
because it was it was outstanding and
and so we'll have to hold off on that
but we're going to a bunch of other
places as well as we're recording this
we're getting ready to go over to
Spokane they're still tickets available
to that we're headed to Portland and
Seattle as well both of those are sold
out so if you're in either one of those
cities and you still want to see us road
trip to Spokane it's not that far we're
driving we're driving from from Missoula
we were actually supposed to do an event
in Missoula but we booked the wrong
venue we booked a thousand seat venue
there's 67,000 people in Missoula and
I'd like to think highly of myself but
it was my fault for not pushing back on
our wonderful booking agent their whole
team I was old that we believed in
ourselves enough he believed in us
enough yeah we were over stretching a
little bit but now I mean Bob Dylan can
get a thousand people in Missoula Josh
what we're not Bob Dylan yeah we're not
even a one-third of Bob Dylan which
means there's two of us dave chappelle
right how do you feel that you're not
even one sixth of Bob Dylan dave
chappelle sold out three nights in a row
of the Denison theater here in a little
yeah and that yeah I feel like we're not
we're not even one twentieth of Dave
Chapelle
we're from the same area though Dayton
Ohio baby yeah so anyway um yeah I am
really looking forward to this next wave
Jes is coming out Shawn is coming out
and and then from there and Matt and
Conrad are coming out to film some stuff
too or working on the next film project
we're not going to tell you what it is
yet but we are super excited for that
we're not even to tell you what format
it is or where it's going to be but we
hope that it's going to be outstanding
we we follow the similar recipe last
time we film something and it became
this documentary that really spread the
message we hope the next thing will
carry that message even even farther
stay tuned for that then after those two
sold-out events there are still tickets
left for the next wave will be in Grand
Rapids
then will be in Chicago that one's
really close selling out if it hasn't
already and then from there Madison
Wisconsin and Minneapolis another a few
seats left in Minneapolis but but not
many I think in Minneapolis just adds up
it's just the VIP seating well okay so
let's talk about that real quick we just
add some clarity so that first wave the
first four cities we did these separate
VIP events before the show in addition
to giving you the good seating or
whatever that didn't work out very well
and so we learned a lesson from that
just like the Missoula lesson we learned
don't look a thousand theater in a
ladies and gentlemen Josh and I fail
miserably still yeah all the time and in
the secret is that you learn from it yes
yeah we probably won't do VIP City
seating or if we do it'll be something
completely different we happy seating
but not the IPF NCI if we add the next
time we do a tour probably knock in a
book the Dennison Theodore Theodore
theater come on Simon
Emily adores all the sudden I become
more than one six of Bob Dylan alright
we've digressed terribly anyway uh yes
VIP events we're going to do better than
just doing a little VIP of them
beforehand if you get a VIP ticket to
any of our events we're going to do
three things for you this time
a you get the best seats in the house
even if its general mission we have
reserved seating for the folks who buy a
VIP ticket second thing we're going to
do is we'll give you all of our copies
of all of our books if you want them
that's totally optional and if you don't
want them then you can pass on obviously
if you want it read it and then pass it
on to someone else who will get value
from it whether that's a library or a
friend or family member or someone else
will give value from it and third after
the event it's free to join the meet and
greet that we didn't want to separate
meet and greet for VIP people because we
like to meet and greet everyone at the
vent for photos and autographs and hugs
especially hugs which by the way are
also totally optional we don't force the
hugs on anyone but you can meet us after
the event and if you're a VIP ticket
holder then you get to jump
line line jumping is a sport for you you
can jump to the front of the line if you
have the VIP ticket so you give se to
the house all of our books and and the
first chance to do the meet-and-greet
after the event which can be pretty long
you know if like a place like the Wilbur
theater where there's over a thousand
people there the meet and greets last a
long time afterward and that's okay
because we got to dish out a hug for
everyone we don't have time to have
conversations after after the event with
a thousand people that that wouldn't
work out just mathematically and because
this is a mathematics podcast we we
don't have time I've done the math we
don't have time to meet every single
person have a full-on conversation but
we still like to meet everyone afterward
give them a hug have a quick hello and
move on with the evening so that's what
the the VIP tickets will get folks from
Minneapolis we're headed to California
after that Los Angeles which does have
more tickets now for those of you who
said it was sold out they opened up some
more seating it's the only venue on the
entire tour where they're going to be
going to do that so otherwise get your
tickets while you can we're also be in
San Diego it's actually before Los
Angeles in San Francisco than
Indianapolis Cincinnati Columbus and
Cleveland and oh by the way next week we
are announcing 22 more cities before the
rest of the year basically the second
leg of the LES is now tour and we're
going to announce that first for our
patreon supporters because I got this
idea from Sam Harris his patreon
supporters they get first access to the
best seats in the House for his podcast
tour which he starting recently or he
starting really soon and so I thought it
was a good idea for the people who are
supporting us they're part of that 1%
they get the first access to get the
best seats in the house if your patreon
supporter is only your patreon supporter
by this weekend then you will get an
email with the first presale access so
that you can snatch up the best seats in
the house for those 22 other cities all
throughout North America and then we
hope to get to overseas next year as
well I know we'll do added value after
the podcast rindy of anything else you
want to talk about in this little intro
no because as literal intros becoming a
bigger intros and I expect
let's get on to the podcast we hope you
enjoyed this Boston event ladies and
gentlemen and stay tuned after the show
for our added value segment and also
some comments and tips from our
listeners hello everybody welcome to the
minimus podcast we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with love
[Applause]
and and we are here with about a
thousand friends in Boston my name is
Joshua fields Wilbur and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist so we have some questions and
Ryan and I hope to have an answer for
you so feel free to step on up give us
your name and we'll we'll start talking
hi I'm Chris I am the leader of the
Boston minimalist group with Cheryl over
here nice my and yes you are an awesome
online group can you stand up so we can
all see who you are and if you would
like a minimalist group please come out
we have monthly meetups our next meetup
is going to be May 7th at 2:30 apiece
coffee or just nice out across the
street at the Boston Greenway and for
those for those of you who don't know
what a minimalist meetup group is back
in 2014 Ryan and I hit the road we did a
hundred cities in ten months we
basically donated a year of our lives
and and decided to leave behind in each
city a meetup group because we don't
have any control over it we just we want
we wanted to leave something behind
because what would happen is we would go
to a city and people come up to us
afterward and say that's great you were
here for an hour or whatever but now
you're leaving how do I connect with
people locally and I would say I don't
know like ok cupid this whole thing ok
um that was a bad answer and so it turns
out we we didn't have a good answer so
we went out and tried to make a good
answer it's called minimalist org you
can go there to click on the Boston
group and it's a Facebook group and and
people need one at least once a month
sometimes groups would meet even more
frequently than that and then you'll get
to surround yourself with either
like-minded people or at least
open-minded people who are willing to be
supportive of whatever changes you want
to make in life and it's not just about
decluttering by the way I'm sure you can
attest that it has to do with finances
or career or anything else that you're
looking for other people that you you
need to support them or
you want to you want their support as
well thank you so much there's also a
Providence group I don't know where she
is but so you guys know you can look up
and Providence too if you're out that
way thank you good night all thank you
Chris
favorites appreciate it hi Josh Ryan
hello Boston my question is actually for
the audience I was wondering how many
people here think that experiences are
more important than things all right
you're in good company yeah I love it
great awesome hey how did my name is
Jenny and I have a question for you guys
about saving money so I know that you
both listen or another at least Ryan
does listen to Joe Rogan podcast and I
think you mentioned Sam Harris once as
well so there's a guy who was on both of
those william makisu will McCaskill yeah
so he has philosophy is anything over
like 35,000 or 40,000 dollars that he
makes he donate and so I would just kind
of want to hear your opinion on what you
like to say if after whatever you need
to live sure
live your meaningful life and whatever
however you feel about that for sure so
she's talking about a guy named lil
McCaskill who runs an organization
called effective altruism who finds the
most effective ways to to contribute
money because not all nonprofits or
charitable organizations are created
equal in fact many of many of them don't
do much good at all while others do
immense good in the world and it's a and
it's hard for us to as regular civilians
to sort of discern how I want to give
you know 100 dollars a dollar a thousand
dollars whatever maybe how do I know the
most effective way to do that
for those of you who are looking for a
place to go there's a great website
called give well.org and they rank the
top 7 most effective Charities in the
world and that list will change
occasionally but they use the algorithms
basically to figure this out and in the
way they do this how many lives they are
saving now obviously saving lives isn't
the only good that we can do with our
money but it seems like the best good
that we can do with our money and I do
think that contribution is important for
at least two reasons first off it's
important because if we if we give we
grow and the more we grow the more we
have to give and it becomes this
beautiful cycle and I can tell you
throughout my solipsistic 20s I was very
much about me me me me me yeah I still
think a lot about myself it's hard not
to write everything that is happening to
me is happening to me right and so
whether it's like I'm sitting in front
of my computer or drinking my coffee or
eating my meal it everything happens to
me but when we can break outside of that
and figure out that yeah there is a
world out there and giving is living and
I know that it almost sounds like a
platitude but it's the absolute truth
and what Ryan and I have found we've had
the capacity to give a lot more over the
last six years even even when I first
walked away from the corporate world I
was I was contributing very little to my
community and I didn't have any money
when I first walked away from the
corporate world I went from making
$200,000 a year which in Dayton Ohio is
probably I don't know half a million
here
it's Dayton Ohio remember Ryan was
aspiring to make fifty thousand dollars
a year
and so we walked away having $23,000
that first year and I contributed more
of that year than I had in the past
decade not monetarily because I couldn't
necessarily afford it I still I still
did a few things monetarily when I could
but I started contributing time so there
was a soup kitchen about two miles away
from my house where I lived
Habitat for Humanity and helped build
several houses with that almost
electrocuted myself one time so I don't
work with wires anymore
but and then beyond that I found that I
can also encourage other people to
contribute as well so over the last few
years and 2015 we made it a mission to
contribute as much as possible so Ryan
and I we along with the help of a lot of
our readers we built an entire school
and louse it was a elementary school for
66 kids who had this Shack essentially
that was just falling down on them and
okay
[Applause]
you should have seen this shag it was
like it was two classrooms in the shack
and they had like a 3-foot wall dividing
them so like the teachers literally
would have to like talk over each other
when they when they would teach and then
when it rained I mean the if they had a
roof and the rain was coming in from
other places and they would have to
cancel school and it was it was just
unbelievable like the to be able to go
over there and you had just like give
them like a really awesome upgrade and I
gotta tell you when when you're welcome
now I thank you for coming but not you
know I remember when we were like at the
party where they were like you know
basically thanking us I partnered with a
non-profit coffee roaster slash cafe
that was over there called Jai
coffeehouse and they were thanking us
and it was it was really funny because
I'm and of course I'm getting this new
translation I didn't practice um on my
my llao llao language but but anyway um
I I remember the guy saying you know
thank you so much to Ryan and Tyson he's
a guy that owns runs Jai coffee house
thank you so much for coming out here
and bringing your American money and
your money is so important to us and you
Americans are great I mean they were
just you know really trying to trying to
talk us talk us up and make us feel good
but when I got to address the the group
and again like it was going back through
translation you know I'm like trying to
make jokes and like they're just not
they're not landing which was fun but I
got to Porter I'm like you know the
money that is that was the easy part
like it was it was that was Tyson and I
got together and we decided to do this
project and and Josh and I have a great
group of readers who wanted to
contribute and that was the easy part
the hard part was for this community to
come together and actually build this
school because literally like
every one that I mean there were family
friends they all knew each other I mean
these little villages and I was like in
America this is what we're lacking we're
lacking this type of community and like
that I saw everyone's head go yeah you
do
thank you but what else do we do that
year we did a ton of yeah and and so I
mean it kind of started with that and
then it snowballed from there we we did
so well and Ryan and I donated a good
chunk of our own money to that but that
really helped his snowball and and all
these other people started contributing
and we had some extra money so we funded
a high school for a year in Kenya and we
built three wells in the Lowry and and
then of course I wanted to do some stuff
back home the following year as well and
then the that terrible Orlando shooting
happened at the pulse nightclub the
terrorist attack there and and like 50
people were killed but 52 people were
injured as well so there were still
people who were alive but needed help
right they had the hospital bills or
they were still in the hospital some of
them and so we did an event in Orlando
and just donated 100% of the proceeds
from that in fact this has been sold up
really quickly and so we decided to do
with all of the presale tickets which is
well over half of the people here we're
using that money from from this
particular event to to build an orchid
orphanage on the us-mexico border and
and I'm really inspired by people like
will McCaskill he lives off of $36,000 a
year or the other British equivalent of
that and he'll justa for a plate
inflation accordingly but you know if
any of you get a chance to listen he did
a couple great interviews with one with
Joe Rogan but the one with Sam Harris
was was phenomenal and Sam does
something great now that after he
interviewed him he takes the first
$3,500 he makes every month and
automatically donates that to to give
well.org give org is the place that I I
tend to give most of my money if I'm
just making a financial contribution
that's your question it's a great
question thanks hi there my name is Gabe
I actually came to your event when you
screened the documentary last year I
remember you yeah and you guys gave me
some really good advice last year about
drudging through the drudgery was judge
spring my junior year you know I was
really killing the crunch and I'm really
happy to say that I took your advice to
heart and I'm now going to college of my
dream school to study design which I'm
super passionate about and so it's
really all Drive one is a David yeah
holy moly
that is beautiful well thanks and so
coming from that you know colleges a is
a big transition from high school and so
I was wondering what advice you guys
have for people on how minimalism can
help with large transitions in your life
whether that be moving or starting a new
job or going to new school or anything
like that
ya know star sure no no I think I think
that's a great point
I feel like right now since you've
already like built each principles into
your life that this is this is not going
to be too tough of a transition because
you know that you have to go into this
very deliberately and you know that
you've got to if this is your dream
school and if this is your you that
you're going for the job that you've
always really wanted to do like you've
got to continue drudging through the
drudgery and I think you know minimalism
what it does it's not that like it makes
it doesn't make the transition easy I
mean in my talk I said like I'm not
talking about a perfect life or easy
life because simple ain't easy like
unfortunately a lot of the times we
confuse simple with easy and that is not
the case in fact it's easy to just go
with the flow it's easy to just go with
your impulses it is hard to go to I
don't know what scooter going to I'm
going to assume Harvard not what is it
oh I'm sorry it's right there and I'm
sure I miss a lot of cues sometimes but
anyway no I'm just I'm just I'm just
saying that now like you have these
principles both you're like you know
what to do and again it's not going to
be easy but at least you know how to
approach and I think the same thing
happens for when you get out of school
you know exactly that you're what kind
of jobs you want to go for you know the
effort you're gonna have to put into it
and you're going to work really hard and
the degree you're going for is it for
six years I think it's four years four
years exam so you're going to work
really hard in the next four years and
then you're probably going to work
really hard another four years after
that trying to pay off your debt but
that's what you know what to do like you
get out of you get let's see he's not
kidding he's not going to spend 30 years
because you cannot hogarth this guy's
question I'm sorry so anyway
so so all I'm saying is like now you
know when you get out of college it's
not how do I get into more debt how do I
go get a mortgage how do I get a new car
oh my god I just got this job I'm making
80 grand a year what debts payments can
I afford like now you know exactly where
to focus and what to do so I would say
yeah man like you've got to have it's
built like you're gonna gave your new
great man thank you so much I really
appreciate that
I'll give you I'll give you two tips two
quick things first off I'm really happy
for you and I just want to say this
though happiness isn't the point and so
keep that in mind there will be times
where it doesn't feel happy and you're
you had you're studying late for a test
and you're sacrificing something else
you're compromising on something else
you want to do so you can do something
that you should do because what you've
done is you've aligned your actions with
your values and so you won't always feel
happy but that's not the point
living a more meaningful life is the
point I think happiness ends up being a
beautiful longer-lasting byproduct of
that but you're not going to feel
perpetually manic just because you
you're going to you're your dream school
and one more question for you who are
you are you getting into debt for this I
actually am very fortunate and my
parents are going to be paying for my
education okay but um the way we sort of
come to an agreement which is I take out
the minimum federal loan for school so
that I have some investment the
investment in my own education and I
listen to your podcast on debt and you
know despite that I actually think it's
a pretty reasonable idea and I really do
like the idea of investing in my own
education and when I come out of it
I know that they have great job
placement programs so I'm confident that
this will not lead me somewhere where
and you know saddled with 20 something
thousand dollars a debt and I'm looking
at and like what the hell do I do about
this so I am I am in an incredibly
fortunate position and so I definitely
want to you know focus my efforts on
maybe making my getting myself out of
death isn't going to be my number one
priority but maybe that's going to be
you know donating the money that I'm
making towards a charity like well
McCaskill is a give well or something
like that so yeah beautiful that's also
no like thanks so much thank you I'll
just I'll just echo so most of you know
my talk on debt there's no such thing as
good debt and and there are many debts
that are far worse than others right I
mean if you go to get a advance payday
loan those have upwards of thirty five
hundred percent interest rates and
someone owns a payday loan store back
there that's ruing yeah and and there
are other there are other there are
other ones that are more responsible but
I and I'm in your shoes I'm doing
whatever I can to avoid any debt
whatsoever or be if I do get into any
debt pay it off as as quickly as I can
and so that I can feel that financial
freedom because that is a huge anchor
and often prevents us from from living
the life we want to live and going in
the direction we want to go howdy hi my
name is Laurie and I have a lot of debt
but that wasn't my question since it
just say free so I am though on that
same line getting back to work after
having two kids who are two and six
right now so I work as a life coach as
an artist as a writer so I am wondering
about reconciling the idea of I know you
guys are writers but also writing
physical books and then also as an
artist making things that adds to the
stuff is in the world so I'm kind of a
non-practicing artist at the moment
because of that conundrum yeah so so we
are minimalist snot deprivation is
there's actually a term for that they're
called ascetics right the
and you can go back several thousand
years and all you can even there are
ascetics today but ascetics believe and
perpetually depriving themselves and
suffering so much that they can
eliminate pain through pain which I have
it worked out the map on yet but my
point being is as I said in my talk
earlier consumption isn't the problem
the problem that we the stuff isn't even
the problem we are the problem and us
being willing to to let go of the notion
that we need what we're supposed to have
allows makes room for what we need what
we want what we like with the things
that add value to our lives and all the
excess stuff is just that it's access
are you guys taking the drink every time
we say add value I hope not well thank
you thank you a question
let's do you do one more long long form
and then we'll move into the lightning
round because we got a lot of questions
so we have we have over a thousand
people here and we certainly can't
answer questions when we're doing the
hug line so we'll try to rapid-fire
through these the lightning round let's
do one more in-depth okay howdy hi I
don't know if this is going to be long
for more lightning round but you guys
can tell me my name is sandy I am a yogi
I'm a yoga teacher and dietitian as well
I live in I don't know about a 325 350
square foot apartment I have a one in
one out rule my friends very
affectionately call it my dollhouse but
I I really appreciate
bringing intention to how I spend my
time and also what I would I have my
objects and I think that that gives a
really important platform for living
authentically which is my greatest value
but if there's times that I struggle and
I think my my question for you guys is
whether it was yesterday or whether it
was six years ago what is something that
stands out in your mind that was a
moment where you struggled with a
decision either to purchase it or to let
it go let me ask you this first what do
you struggle with if it's the lightning
round
now I want to be able to answer your
question better honestly I mean if
there's something because here's the
honest truth everyone here including
myself we were all struggling with
something and we all have these
struggles that we stumble upon and and I
think the best parts of me are made up
of my past struggles and so and then of
course the best parts of my future self
will be made up of what I'm struggling
with now because as I struggle through
those things I'm able to grow and so so
yeah I could definitely talk about my
struggles and Ryan to talk about his but
is there something that really stands
out you want me to share first look no
Billy yes I guess to clarify I'm talking
about objects but today very much
I guess it's why I'm asking because I do
believe that there's growth that comes
from those struggles and that evaluation
process but I guess I'm asking about
about objects whether it was a purchase
whether or not you purchase something or
whether or not or whether was getting
rid of something from from your
possessions yeah I think the the objects
and I told understand what you're saying
but I think I don't delineate the
objects from me because I think the
material possessions are a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
of me and so when I had here the three
hundred thousand things in my house a
very ordinal system of alphabetized DVDs
and and CDs and bins and boxes it was
really just because like I wasn't
dealing with what was going on and
inside me and so that was like my
biggest struggle was was pretending it
wasn't there yeah I'll tell you the
biggest and I actually the show rule
pretty much any time I'm in my tour bus
you know the the 2004 Toyota Corolla
that's in the documentary
and every time it rains it leaks it's
someone sent me an e-mail a God love
them they're like you need it because it
has like a sunroof and it's like you
need to get the track cleaned around it
and it'll it'll you know you'll be fine
and that is exactly what's going on
except I brought it to the mechanic to
fix it and he was like dude it is
clogged
he's like I can't I can't fix it he what
he said he could but then like it would
just cost more than what the car is
worth so every time it rains like I feel
that like water dripping out my head and
I'll make like a corner and then like
the water starts dripping on Mariah's
head and then like regrettin tissues and
like trying to like the hold one of the
holes and looking at each other like we
should just get another car and but very
quickly I'm like you know this water
dripping on my head is not nearly as bad
as that debt payment I would have to
take on and so really I mean I do
struggle with stuff you don't deprive
yourself I guess that's what I would
tell you when it comes with the objects
you know I got I have a Stein beer stein
that my grandmother gave me when I was
in high school and I use it for like
putting all my loose change in but
that's time is well it means a lot to me
like it is very sentimental my
grandmother is she's not doing really
well and I'm just like now it's hitting
me I'm like oh man like you know I just
got to spend as much time as I can with
her at this point and I probably won't
ever let go of that Stein like I will
probably always hold on to that and I
would never just get rid of something
because of my will I'm a minimalist I
can't I can't hold on to this night now
if I went home and it spontaneously
combusts I'd be like damn it really like
that sign
but I do know that the memory in that
you know isn't in that sign it is inside
of me um but again I would never just
get rid of it just for the sake of while
I'm a minimalist and I'm going to get
rid of that sign
so don't deprive yourself your turn I
forgot one for you so you go first and
I'll go right I love that you chose to
have the benefit of being closer to the
earth with your with your water dripping
on your head that's all I've had a
refrain that okay I'm going to hold that
side that's good that's good my mom's
vintage Levi's shirt yeah
you wear it yeah yeah keep it you have
our permission but really you don't need
our permission though you need your
permission and if it's May if it's
making you feel that bad to let it go
I mean if it's if it's one shirt then
yeah hold on to it I mean if you were
like I have you know hordes and hordes
and hordes of my mother's old newspapers
and clippings and then I would be like
it we have a completely different
conversation actually I probably one of
the professional organizers to help you
out because they know the best way to
organize is to get rid of most of your
stuff but uh but yeah I mean if it's if
it's a incidental teacher like there is
a point where yeah you don't want to
just throw something away just for the
sake of it um yeah I mean it doesn't
sound to me like you have have a huge
hoarding problem but the thing is that I
would I would always ask when there's
something like that that's bothering you
like so for whatever reason it may be
bothering you but the other question I
might have is how could you what in what
other ways could you use it you know
I've seen people take old shirts like
that and have it framed and turn
- artwork works like it's my mom's old
vintage Levi's shirt and I'm no longer
wearing it it's not the best thing for
me to wear anymore because you know it
doesn't set me just writer or whatever
and you can actually turn it into a
piece of art I've seen people do that
with photographs as well whether like
here's a bunch of photos I didn't want
to scan because they're kind of silly
but there are places who were artists
will take those and they'll turn them
into collages and so yeah you can do
something else you can you can repurpose
those things for me my my struggle is is
in a weird way a struggle by proxy and
what I mean by that is I you know so my
life is I'm 35 now and my life is
considerably different from what it was
when I was 28 when I first embraced
minimalism I have a partner we live
together and we have a three-year-old
daughter and she likes different stuff
from what I do right and so I'm
constantly looking at other people's
stuff even though we're a minimalist
household all three of us are minimalist
Ella can't pronounce it yet but she
tries she has minimalist and and
actually by the way it's it's great when
first time she asked me like what is
minim lalala ilysm and and you know I
have my little you know stock answer
minimal terms of thing that gets his
past the things that so we can make room
for life's most important things which
actually are things at all and then I'm
trying to explain what a homonym is to
her and and it's nice because I find
that that dealing with other people's
stuff helps me appreciate their needs as
well realize you know it's not just
about me it's about we and I don't just
want to tolerate this person's stuff
whether it's my close family or friends
but anyone I want to go beyond now and
respect the person who they are
and appreciate them for who they are
warts and all because I want people to
appreciate me as well thanks your
question good question
all right well for the people who are
listening at home if you have a comment
or tip for anyone to get asked the
question today you can give us a call at
four zero six two one nine and seven
eight three nine where our favorite
comments and tips on the next episode
also if you can now take your phone out
and actually recording a voice memo and
send that through podcast at the
minimalists comm that will end up going
to the podcast Shawn by the way can we
get a round of applause or podcast show
yeah love you Shawn there's no one back
there fiddling and yeah well we'll air
those tips and tricks from our callers
on the next episode Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
our hashtag at the minimalist lightening
round yesterday week we we do our best
here to answer each question with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response usually we get these questions
from Instagram or or Twitter or Facebook
where we're here today so will Ryan and
I have been doing while we're on the
road is is competing and what we try to
do is we compete to give the Pythias
answer and you all get to be the judge
so in by the way if we don't have a pet
the answer sometimes will ramble a bit
what is this qualify ourselves and
ramble how did what you guys Mary Anne
so this is my first minimalist event my
friend brought me she's over there so
this is the perfect event for me right
now
because I'm in a transition I'm moving
I'm looking for my next position career
job and I work in education and I have a
champagne taste on a beer budget and
somehow through my twenty
erh 1981 through my 20s I racked up a
lot of debt credit card debt and I'm
trying to change my ways so my question
to you growing up
family members big into Christmas
birthdays presents material items all
that jazz is it is it possible at my age
and then also how do you kind of like
get your family on board and your
friends when they've known you to be a
Shopaholic or going to this or doing
that can you hit that 140 characters
with the no Kadima which has two
questions
yep I would say the people in your life
who love and appreciate you they will
support you no matter what
remember this Jeff Foxworthy joke you
might be a redneck remember those right
like that was that key thing you might
be a minimalist and yeah
how does it feel your how about this how
about this you might be broke if you
have a car payment you have a credit
card payment you have a credit card you
have a student loan payment you have a
30-year mortgage period now I did
qualified that's that's totally Sean can
you give us character I'm kidding okay
I'll give you that one I'll give you
that one thing we've got this qualified
you are you got much better applause
than I did so why you're my best friend
so I will give you a much longer answer
so you haven't listened to our podcast
yet and I'm going to encourage you to go
back and listen to two episodes of it
episode number 60 is an entire two-hour
long excursion on finances ok and
there's a long time ago a year ago we
recorded a podcast on money it's episode
number 12 and both of those dive pretty
deep and once you've listened to those
we also have a couple essays on our
website the one that sticks out my mind
right away it is it's called financial
freedom 5 difficult steps to get out of
debt and that's the most honest title I
could give because it is difficult to
get out there but it is so so worth it
yeah thanks thank you
hi um I hope this isn't redundant in my
name is Tessa
so my redundant oh right he's got a
light on back there I'm sorry that is
really distracting thank you
so my dad passed away last summer
and we my brother and I my mom's not
really involved so we have the dreaded
storage locker and I have a box in my
apartment my brother I was in the
apartment in New York I live in Boston
so we just don't have a place for the
stuff so I guess my question is like
I'll get rid of my stuff fine but I have
I cannot like get rid of my dad's stuff
and I'm like waiting for the moment that
Josh had I feel really guilty like I
just can't do it
so I don't know if there's a helpful
like words for that and then also like
what about the family legacy stuff like
the furniture that like I know my dad
would want to have like do we keep the
storage locker toy buy a house like what
do we do also my dad's above you guys so
he didn't have a lot of stuff but we
still have the storage locker
you go first happy I know it's
especially tough getting into a tweet
I've never liked I've never regretted
anything I've let go of but if I ever do
I'll let go of the regret
[Applause]
I can't man umm-hmm
I can't be that what here's my pity
answer but that it won't it won't be
that was good man what I would say is if
you don't ever start you're going to be
waiting the rest of your life and I
think it you haven't read our book
everything that remains
I don't know I'm an avid podcast
listener not books yet yeah yeah that's
okay I love the easily agape I don't
feel like I'm selling you a copy of our
book which are by the way available in
Elle in the lobby but I could be honest
it 100 percent of the profits go to to
our our favorite charity it's the the
get the Josh and Ryan gas fun to get to
Portland Maine tomorrow now seriously
but honestly the way afterward if you
come out and you want a book and you
can't afford one let us buy you want I'd
be more than happy to buy you a book or
if you just forgot your wallet or
something but for asking that question I
think you'll find a lot of value and
everything that remains it's a five year
story for about me and Ryan we we made
this transition from well organized
hoarders to minimalist you know these
corporate guys and and the second
chapter in there it will especially
resonate with you yeah thank you thank
you thank you
I'll try to be more pity that's right as
many as we can here alright hi fellas my
name is France I'm having some
difficulties framing this question but I
think it's a quick one I feel like I've
had a disclaimer before I asked it you
know number one I always support a very
strong social safety net I think as
Americans we have a responsibility to
protect the very vulnerable one thing I
picked up on when you were telling your
story if you both came from similar
childhoods where you lived on government
assistance and your parents struggled
with alcohol and drugs and I was
wondering how you are able to overcome
adversity
- first kind of ride that first wave of
success or you are financially and
professionally very successful but then
you're on the second wave of success
where you are able to adopt the
philosophy of minimalism and so I was
wondering what makes you different from
other people that are struggling how did
you get to that headspace to accept this
because if you think stereotypically
people that are disadvantaged they don't
get there so I was wondering did you
have a mentor did you read something
early on that put you on this path yeah
I got to start this one go for it if you
want to make money
actually I set this over yes start the
track over delete delete' if you want to
be rich go get a sales job but you're
going to [ __ ] hate it
[Music]
that was my answer no Shawn hi get some
time on the clock so yeah thank you
thank you thank you that's helpful
but there are two reasons we make
changes fear and meaning and I feared
staying in my previous life more than I
feared
making the change yeah I'm sorry going
to be disqualified on that I think that
was a tie on that one yeah all right
real quick that that is beyond the
honest truth it I
I was very narrowly successful and in
the corporate world and and that was not
real success right that the real success
is its pursuing a life that is that
aligns with your values and that was not
the life I was living and and now I am
and it's an imperfect life but it's so
much better thanks for the question
thank you howdy hi oh hi Jocelyn Ryan my
name is Ashley I'm an avid podcast
listener your documentary and podcast
have truly made an impact on our
family's life have someone you've seen
our documentary
well there is pretty much one person you
can thank for that
and he's right back here the Italian
stallion Maddy Avella seriously this guy
I can't wait until like he's maybe
that's awesome like documentary I just
know he's gonna be an awesome
documentarian I'll be like you know that
about he did our first movie if we were
his first movie yeah and and and we also
have Conrad back here who is helping us
film so let's give him a round of
applause well thank you for being a
level six Conrad we have no idea what
we're filming by the way we're just kind
of filming and seeing what happens
because it worked out really well last
time we did that and so we figure why
not try that again so we're out here
listening once again and I will continue
listening so you've made such an impact
that there are many places in our home
that now echo that is the sound of
minimalism in your most recent podcast
you spoke about how clothing seasons
have evolved over the past several
decades we've gone from two seasons to
four seasons to fifty two seasons to
what's on trend as a parent as parents
we've adopted the two seasons of
clothing with our children's wardrobe I
know that you've discussed project 333
but as a parent I buy and plan my
children wardrobes in advance so that I
can purchase things when they're on sale
or friends has something that's used I'm
very analytical in nature
can you help parents quantify the items
necessary for a child's to season
wardrobe for example five dresses for
girls two pairs of pants five pairs of
pants long sleeves
what if Ella's wardrobe look like
how much was the answer that I know I
got you go first I'll find a bigger one
okay my short answer here okay I was
working I look like lots of stripes but
that's not my answer about my choice
here we go here we go could be missing
sale price right so most of us I mean
let me let me get it tweetable here sale
price now full price is often the
intentional price because sale price is
full price
[Music]
I'm going to actually I can't process it
but purposes that's kind of cheating I
think what else says you and your
husband get to set boundaries
you don't need anybody's permission to
do anything but yours are we tied at
this point I think we need a tiebreaker
at least right yeah did I I don't really
keep school on this a month well we'll
treat this well actually no it will do
two more and then well if we still need
a tiebreaker after that then we'll keep
going but I know they'll kick us out of
here pretty quickly man so how do I
Randy from Oakdale nice balcony to
dessert awesome
all right so about a year ago I adopted
the middle of philosophy and kind of got
me down a path thinking about what adds
value of my life and material goods is
kind of one thing but I kind of like to
know you guys opinion on relationships
and how you assess value in
relationships
okay I'll use this one because I think I
know I'd like use this before so I'm
totally pulling out my old material here
[Music]
it doesn't matter whose blood someone
has in their veins I invest in people
who invest in me yeah well since we're
pulling out old material you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you what do you
think that was totally me all right we
got one more all right we got we got one
more you could tie it up here all right
hi my name is Leanne Haley yeah I don't
know if this is a question for you guys
or for like a life coach but you deli
sighs I'm definitely not a life coach
I have more life experience than many
life coaches
oh I'm not bashing on life coach as many
of them are great it's just a Joe to
plan words no but they really do have
more education than us though for sure
at some point really I guess I'm just
looking for some direction you downsize
you minimize you lower get out of your
debt now what what do you look for you
know I don't know what I'm looking for
in life you me go yeah go if you gotta
go Kay okay so if I were to rephrase
your question it sounds to me what
you're saying once of stuff is out of
the way then what right okay yeah like
how do you find a value like what's
value and meaning to you yeah so in
order to live a meaningful life you must
align your short term actions with your
long term values
they held back their applause for me
because I want this to keep going it
doesn't wait no dammit that was that no
that's a good one
I kind of wanted to keep going to know
um I'll tell you what he said is I get
but no there's when I got it I got to
put I got to put this into each size
form um if you aren't clear on what your
values and beliefs are you're going to
be lost the rest of your life
now josh is what he just whispered was
much better than that you are what you
desire thank you thank you all right
here comes the tiebreaker hi Ryan hi
Josh howdy I'm fine
repping San Diego California nice oh wow
that's a bit of a bit of a drive okay
I've made that drive before really yeah
yeah that's cool 2014 water coming on my
head off the whole time oh yeah
we went from Missoula to Florida to like
LA basically coast to coast to coast to
coast it was it was unbelievable anyway
you guys blog about me more about your
quest okay yeah yeah good idea
um so I've watched her documentary like
five six times so I'm a practicing
minimalist but in terms of my parents
they're just not on board and you know
they're like 50 something years old now
and how do you sorry
55 I know I should know my parents age
right that's not their laughing anyways
okay they've been laughing at me all
night you'll get used to it okay sounds
good um but yeah how do I get them on
board and you know it's tough because
they're set in their ways and it's just
the older generation who's just I'm so
sorry yeah they're probably going to
hate me by their face no it's
chronologically true your parents are
older than you and a generation ahead
I'm 27 by the way but yeah what do you
think about you know age group and
okay we might need to stop talking there
you go no you're doing great yeah and
you got some you can't change the people
around you oh man um I kind of just want
to like I just want to pass and give it
to you man a lot of for some reason I
feel like it's easier just for fit then
uh hold on you think for a second you've
all right you have you got one go all
right all right
people don't hate change they hate being
changed
wish I would've thought of that one
bottom of the ninth yeah
full count alright this is a line come
up with um if you truly love your
friends and family want them to be happy
you will support them in their happiness
thank you are you gonna drop the mic
what's that are you gonna drop the mic
no I'm sorry we can't get through the
rest of them but we I know I know if you
wait actually oh no no afterward we're
not going to question we're in about 15
minutes we don't if you tweet us we will
tweet you back I promise you'll get an
answer on Twitter yes always about try
to communicate with oh sorry guys but we
and about fifteen or twenty minutes
we'll be out there if anyone wants to
stick around we will fish out some hugs
we've got some books out there as well
like I said if you if you can't afford
or you or you just didn't bring your
your wallet with you you're welcome to
grab one up what will will buy one for
you I want to thank the louver for
having us here thank you so much amazing
staff amazing venue
yeah like thank you so much
as always if you leave here with one
let's issue we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
[Applause]
alright Joe it is time for our added
value portion of the show this is a Ryan
and I talk about what's adding value to
our lives or recently Ryan what has been
adding value to your life I know you've
been travelling like crazy so you've had
less of an opportunity to to take in
some of the same creations that I've
taken in recently but we're even
enjoying lately um well on the plane
ride over to Ono's a plane ride back
from Tokyo I watched moonlight uh-huh
dude yeah I'd know why I won't ask her
why along best picture yeah it was
dude phenomenal phenomenal movie saga
guy loved it great writing great just a
great perspective mm-hmm um yeah I don't
want to ruin it for anyone moonlight is
a great movie I've also been watching
this series on Netflix called dear white
people
uh-huh the title is very subversive like
it makes you feel like it's a one-sided
series ha ha it is not one-sided
I haven't even heard of it it does a
beautiful job of it shows basically like
these different events that happen in
this college and it shows it through the
different perspectives of black and
white people and it just does a great
job of showing like hey here's why
here's why white privilege is a problem
and then that's the other perspective of
hey white privilege isn't the only
problem right it just does a really good
job of balancing between these two like
black or white you know well I shouldn't
say they're black white people like to
make a blacker way no pun intended
yeah um but I like to make it by an area
is what you're saying yeah they like to
make a binder and it's not and it just
does a great job of showing both
perspectives good
and bad and I just don't want to go into
too much use I don't want to run it but
dear white people is great moonlight is
great I'm going to change my
recommendation based on that I'm reading
the book right now I'm not all the way
through it but it follows in that same
vein it's by Charlemagne it's called it
just came out last month in April it's
called black privilege operating
opportunity comes to those who would
black privilege opportunity comes to
those who seek it I think is the
subtitle of it is it as is it is it like
it because to me like that type just
like dear white people sounds very
subversive a black privilege sounds like
a very all lives matter type thing no
it's the opposite of that in fact I mean
he's a black man obviously and in
Charlemagne is of your famous radio host
and commentator a TV show host okay and
what he thought he man he recognizes
there is something called your white
privilege and he doesn't and that can be
systemic but he looks at what we all
have our own type of privilege and for
him it's a privilege to be black or I
was losing to Chris Hardwick on the
Nerdist podcast recently talk about how
people often tweet him about hey you
need to check your privilege and he
looks at it says tweeted from iPhone and
it's like well you have iPhone privilege
right and we are the two billion of us
that are on the internet have internet
privilege and it doesn't mean that there
isn't a such thing as white privilege
there there is especially in the Western
world or in America in particular but we
also have the opportunity to create our
own outfit our own privilege so it is
not like in all lives matters I think is
that facilitates the hell out of me the
no it's the opposite of that it's he's a
black man who's showing look there are
systemic problems we're not all
necessarily created equal or or come
from an equal place he grew up in a
trailer park in Moncks Corner South
Carolina and didn't have much going for
him got arrested very young and realized
he needed to retake regain control of
his life and now he's wild
successful not just like monetarily
successful or celebrity successful
that's not how he's measuring success
but he's living the life he wants to
live he's contributing his way beyond
himself and that's because he recognized
I may not have white privilege but I
have some sort of privilege in my life
let me take advantage of whatever
situation I'm in let me make the best of
it is really what he's saying and he he
writes about the seven different
principles in his life that have changed
his life also each chapter checking a
different principle and your life yeah
it's really good and also a Backson I
just started watching the third season
of Fargo it just came out I started it's
you and McGregor plays two different
characters in it well so good that's so
good I can't wait to like forgot yes I
forget totally forgot about that you
they can't wait to serve a very few
shows that I look forward to watching
and Fargo s10 arena 3-3 at this
recording and it's so good they can't
wait - yeah Mar is going to be so
excited and we just finished um actually
I don't want to talk about the shows
that we just finished because they're
kind of lame I would not recommend them
to other be there shows that we started
watching and got hooked on haha but I
would not recommend that I drop out and
so I had a previous recommendation I
recommended the Americans and it was a
decent show but I lost my entrance our
season Mex kept going the only reason we
watch these two shows is because of the
cliffhangers that they leave and it's
like and they are like decently no
they're not decently but I learned a
walk away from a man like I saw their
comedy so and they're like they make us
laugh that's really critical that's
important yeah well I don't want I don't
want to drag this intro out too long in
an intro this is an outro Ryan oh I mean
I don't want to drag this out - well
real quick so added value so I just
recommended black privilege and then I
recommended fargo season 3 season 3 it's
so you know backs is from Minnesota and
Fargo the whole thing takes place in
Minnesota I don't know why they called
for it I get I get a whole new
perspective watching this with her
because her family is special especially
certain people and her family and her
friends have this little bit of the the
Minnesota accent and so you hear these
these Minnesota Minnesota isms maybe at
anyway you hear these little things in
their vernacular that she says from time
to time
and it's so cute it's just like adorable
I'm watching this it gives me this whole
other perspective so real quick moving
you have a girlfriend or boyfriend from
Minnesota you will have a new
appreciation for their their vernacular
yeah I think so it's just an
appreciation for the way that they were
raised and like the third episode takes
place in Los Angeles and it's this weird
thing like it's this exaggerated version
of Los Angeles so it's like oh we're all
stuck in traffic
it must be Los Angeles a sipping lattes
in traffic right yeah that kind of thing
and of course it's an exaggerated
version of Minnesota too because accents
aren't actually that thick and and
really it was comparing the rural world
world rural world the real world world
yeah and I have trouble with elves man
rural world and and then of course the
city life as well so it sort of
contrasted those two and I'm really
enjoying I enjoyed the first two seasons
a lot recommend though the first season
was outstanding the second one I
might've cycle I might have liked the
second one better although it's and it
was rated really well it was at least
equal to the first one so like I agree
yeah and what and that's hard to do
because producers lives like they don't
really know yeah I liked it they all
have their own plots and they all have
their own characters that you love or
hate but you're invested in either way
so this microphone was getting heavy
yeah so I'm going to move on real quick
to right here right now I had one of the
recommendations but I'll save it for the
next episode right here right now Ryan
and I are on the road right now we're
headed to 40 cities this year the less
is now tour find your city find your
date find your theater where we're going
to be over at les is now.com this has
been so great so far and I know it's
going to get even better from here also
the minimalist podcast is often the
number one health podcast on iTunes and
an occasionally charts in the top 10 of
all shows and this year we're going to
build a new podcast in film studio and
the microphone in my or the microphone
what is this a stand the boom mic it's
something it's heavy and I'm holding it
because it fell off the table anyway
we're building in the new podcast a film
studio and since we refuse to clutter
our podcast with advertisers need your
help so we created a patreon page what
is patreon you ask patreon is a website
that allows people who
great stuff like the minimalist podcast
to support their own or to build their
own subscription service and allow our
listeners to contribute on a per episode
basis we're asking our listeners to
contribute two bucks per episode to help
us build a studio so we can reach more
folks with our simple living message by
the way the min was typically publish we
publish one Episode a week usually
occasionally - but patreon allows you to
set a monthly cap on your contribution
so we start to publish a million
episodes a month you don't have to worry
about that also if you want to support
us you can't afford to support us this
month the month of May 2017 we're
donating $10 for every iTunes review we
receive so if you if you even if you
give us a one so obviously we prefer a
five-star review because it makes us
feel warm and fuzzy but that's actually
not why we prefer it it gets our message
in front of more people our podcast gets
recommended to more people via their
algorithm so you can help us do that but
you can also help save some lives here
we're donating all of the funds so far
we have over 200 new reviews this month
so we've raised over $2000 or you've
raised over $2,000 ryan and i are
donating the money to the against
malaria foundation $3500 saves one life
so if you want to help us save a life
pause the podcast right now take 30
seconds leave us a review we will donate
$10 in your name to the against malaria
foundation this month Ryan you got
anything else no man all I have are some
comments and tips from our listeners hi
my name is Amanda and I'm a teacher in
Revelstoke BC Canada and this answer is
for Pam regarding what she should do
with all of that paper that comes with
being a secondary school teacher so I've
been teaching since 2005 and since 2010
I've been using an online platform
called blogger to create daily posts on
everything that I do in class including
all handouts videos just a total review
of each daily schedule for every one of
my classes and this has been a massive
help in so many different areas so it
saves me a ton of paper because all I
need to do is eat
today what I do is take all of my
handouts I just take one of each and I
go down to the office and I scan it
through our photocopier there that also
scans it scans directly to my email I
then go back to my classroom grab the
scans pop those scans into either
Dropbox or Google Docs and create a link
and then embed those on my blog through
blogger and it only takes me about 10 to
15 minutes now to do that every day for
all of my classes so to get a blogger it
is free you just need to have a gmail in
order to set it up you just go to
blogger.com
and what's really wonderful since 2010 -
now my school district I would say about
80 to 90% of the teachers have blogs and
as I said it helps a ton with just paper
and having everything online but when
you have say the same class the
following year you can just go to your
old blog pull off stuff right from there
if you don't have all that paper but an
added benefit that I've seen is that for
both students and parents there are so
many advantages to having a teacher blog
so for students when a student is away
or they're sick or anything like that
when they come back to school they know
now that is their responsibility to grab
whatever they've missed from my blog and
have it ready to hand in
so they because they can just download
everything and fill stuff out online
from my blog they don't need to come
back and I don't need to find all the
paper that Dave missed and try and track
it all down it's right there on the blog
and further for parents I found the blog
is super helpful because every single
day I update it so every single day
parents know exactly what their child's
done in class what handouts have been
provided what's for homework what
they've watched with regards to any
video resources so the parents I've
found that have come to me have been so
thankful for this because they really
feel like they're tied into what their
child is doing on a daily basis and they
can refer back to my blog anytime they
want to
you offer their child more assistance if
they needed at home I don't claim to be
a minimalistic but I have to say you
guys have absolutely inspired me to
declutter and that's what I've been
doing for the past year I've also been
trying to help out my 80 year old mother
hey ma what's this I don't know it was
last time you use it I don't know can I
get rid of it sure it's been working
pretty well now she's going into a
nursing home and I never realized how
much paperwork
she had drawers and drawers filled with
paperwork if statements canceled checks
warranties receipts for 20 years and I
can't find the deed to our house so I
have to go through all of it so my tip
is watch out for the paperwork if you're
helping somebody declutter hey Josh and
Ryan this is Ethan from Denver Colorado
I just had a suggestion for your
listeners something that I've started
doing that I found a lot of value in and
it's doing a 5 5 minute meditation every
single time when I get in the car before
I'm going anywhere if I've got the time
which I usually do and I'm honest with
myself ask myself do I really have time
five minutes to spare and usually the
answer is yes and usually I find that I
enjoy it so much that I make the time
but I do a five minute meditation before
driving anywhere especially if it's
going to be a long drive it's even more
likely that I make sure to do this but I
I do five minutes just I set the timer
on my phone for five minutes I just sit
there close my eyes and I focus on my
breath and it's been really incredible I
feel so much more free and it creates
this space between the drive which can
be so stressful and just I feel more
spacious and free in my life because of
it so highly recommended
[Music]
you
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing using that me every
little thing that just feeding your
greenido I bear that you beside me
without every little thing that you got
a headache
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I
bear thank you son without such a 40
[Music]
you
you
[Music]